joining us now former Florida attorney
general Pam Bondi and criminal defense
attorney Mark gagos good to have you
both Pam let's get your take on this
release what does it mean to
you well it's trickled out Sean it's
trickling out first of all it should
have come out a long time ago Professor
dtz wanted it out and by the way he is
one of the best attorneys in this
country I know him I know his wife
that's a great family and they've been
dragged through hell on this I want to
know why AG Garland and the justice
department are so quiet on this tonight
you know they're out there labeling
parents domestic terrorists yet they're
saying nothing about this and these
documents were so slow to come out um
human trafficking is a multi-billion
doll business in this country and
Jeffrey Epstein is dead and geran
Maxwell is in prison for 20 years where
she belongs and if people in that report
are still fighting to keep their names
private Sean they have no legal basis to
do so unless they're a child a victim or
a cooperating defendant by some chance
against some potential case against
geran Maxwell and I think Mark gagos as
a great criminal defense attorney will
back that up as well you know Mark let
me go to you um there are a lot of
people that Professor dtz has
represented that that frankly I never
liked and really don't understand why he
would take on these so high-profile
cases uh you're just like professor ttz
you've taken on a lot of high-profile
cases um and I know you've paid a pretty
dear price for representing people with
the belief that everybody has a right to
a a defense um and you paid a price for
that what is your take on
tonight you know my father who was my
hero and was a former prosecutor I
remember going to him over 20 years ago
when I was asked to represent Scott
Peterson and you know was one of those
things where he was the most hated man
in the world and he said if you're not
going to take this case cuz you're
worried about your reputation then why
do you do what you do which I I kind of
live by and I think I've talked with
Allan over the years and we've
represented many of the same people and
talked about kind of the thankless job
that it is it's been rewarding for both
of us intellectually and financially but
at the same time you got to suffer the
slings and arrows and I will tell you
that it's easy to make accusations it's
a lot tougher when you're Allan trying
to defend yourself against the uh
allegations and watching him and the
pain he's gone through for the last
couple of years and I've talked to him
uh more than one occasion about the the
toll that it's taken on him I I I kind
of chuckled to myself when he was
talking about losing all the friends
because he represented Trump I've said
some of the things the the most uh
hateful comments I've ever gotten is
when I represented Republican uh
political fundraisers so I I I feel his
pain and probably not uh to the level
exponentially that he has because of
trump but it's a it's a function of this
system if you believe in the
Constitution if you believe in an
adversarial system then you then you
need somebody to do it not just walk
through the motions somebody who will
fight zealously I've never met a client
yet who came to my office and said I
just want somebody to be window dressing
and sit by here and not really put up a
defense you want somebody going to fight
for you and I've had countless clients
that have been innocent and we've proven
it what about Bill Clinton how does he
factor into this when we know he's a
liar we know the issue of Monica
Lewinsky I've got to believe that a lot
of Americans suspect there might be some
truth to this especially with the number
of times he was on the plane which I
believe contradicted his public
statement if I recall correctly
Pam well SE Sean we know one of the
witnesses about
this uh hang on Pam first
Pam and well we know he was on the plane
not only on the plane a couple times
multiple times he traveled
internationally
internationally with Jeffrey Epstein and
he was on the plane called the Lolita
Express because it supposedly had a bed
in there where Jeffrey Epstein had young
girls um he has been a friend of his A
continuing friend of his for years and
years contrast out with Donald Trump who
hasn't spoken to him in many years over
a decade after he kicked him out of Mara
Lago for bad behavior so that's the
difference there and I think Americans
see the two-tier justice system um but
you know we don't know they they're
saying Clinton has not been to his
private island but he has traveled all
over the world with Jeffrey
Epstein well over time let's see and if
the judge judge does have other
information that would add context and
texture to a list I do believe the judge
has an obligation to release it
especially because people's names or
reputation are in play here yes uh Pam
thank you Mark aragos thank you hey Sean
Hannity here hey click here to subscribe
to Fox News YouTube page and catch our
hottest interviews and most compelling
analysis you will not get it anywhere
else